so I went to his uh to his car he pops
his trunk and he goes and he goes oh man
the soup outside
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right y'all we're gonna watch a
little video we're gonna react to the
video it feels like school when they
roll in the TV right and uh this is a
doordash delivery driver
oh it's an Asian guy looks like a JK fan
oops this store that's custom I only tip
one dollar let's see what he got at
Arby's huh
it's got the beef and cheddar
he's got the French dip
and the crinkle fries oh man that's my
favorite
thank you one dollar Tipper peace
what the [__] that's pretty funny hey
let's go
JK fan right there is that the
Vietnamese what is it hey don't be
looking at me asking me Vietnamese
that's what I was thinking can you
detect that's why you have to you have
to put up he looks half he looks half
Vietnamese and then yeah so it doesn't
it's not open she's spoken like a true
business owner who delivers actually a
very mild thing to do though just eat a
fry but isn't that what the big
companies do he must have opened it yeah
because they seal it because yeah the
big like seal it with the official
stickers it's basically tamper-proof you
can't get it open you can't because when
you're hungry and you get your delivery
it takes five minutes not even the bomb
squad could get it open yeah they refuse
to work on those yeah the robot just
turns around
it shrugs
but then if the meal's like five bucks
and then they get tipped a dollar that's
20 I mean that had a lot of items in it
so it probably wasn't yeah definitely
not every restaurant that delivers seals
up the [__] tamper-proof for like ties
the bag Etc Joe when's the last time you
ordered fast food
I order fast food this morning and it
cost me 10 bucks to buy four hash browns
exactly you went to the store I mean
delivery delivery yeah put see five
bucks you're never gonna spend five
bucks on delivery ever never never I
think tipping one dollar is kind of like
because you can have the option to
choose your tip that means he chose this
tip and just put a dollar that almost
seems like you're going out of your way
kind of be a dick I think most people
don't tip there's a lot of no tippers
like oh for food delivery specifically
if you put no tip at all can you do that
okay so you so back well now now I'm
getting scared about the [__] tipping
culture nowadays but back in the days I
used to just automatic tip and then
without automatic tip there would be you
know there would be rainy day situations
sometimes somebody wouldn't show up my
food or wouldn't get delivered or XYZ
would happen right like it would be the
wrong order so then I was like you know
what I'm a tip after yeah like I'm gonna
get my thing and then when I know I have
everything in my thing I'll tip right
but then now I'm like [__] dude like I
don't want to like not tip before how
I'm personally pissed at me and do XYZ
to my food or whatever and you know what
I mean like and I won't know why don't
they make it like [__] when you get
an Uber ride at the end after your ride
you tip I don't know they always ask you
in the beginning why but you can also
add more tip if they were like really
good so you tip to make sure that they
don't [__] up and then you tip more
because they were on time or fast or
whatever they were nice but the thing is
you're already still paying delivery
fees surcharge taxes and all this stuff
when you're ordering five dollars only
like a delivery you got a tip and tip
after you're spending like 14 bucks
that's why I'm so split on it because
I'm like
aren't you doordash's employee like they
pay you and if I pay doordash the
delivery fee they pay you from that I
still tip just because I'm like I don't
know what the [__] to do but yeah
because back in the day when stores
deliver like well people still deliver
like pizza and stuff right that's
because it's like you're tipping a
waiter yeah so you're tipping them they
don't they don't get a delivery fee
there's no delivery fee for ordering
pizza you just order the pizza and then
you tip the driver yeah well I don't
like it in restaurants nowadays and it's
just so common so like there's nothing
to not like because it's just the world
we live in just the way it is yeah just
nowadays you go up to the register they
don't do anything you're putting your
order and then they turn the [__]
iPad I hate that [__] like you said it's
already on fifteen percent
and you're getting it to go yeah and
it's like wait a minute like what is
tipping culture nowadays you know if I'm
taking it to go I go
zero thank you no print receipt thank
you if they're really nice if I get some
good service or something and it's just
a kiosk I'll tip like a couple bucks
maybe but for the most of the time if
I'm grabbing and going during the
pandemic though I was 20 like 25 all the
time but I'm like I was like these
[__] mom and pop shops need to stay
open I was doing that chipotle I was
like these people I hope they stay here
do you guys have any good or bad uh like
delivery stories or stuff that happened
I've had people I've we've ordered Boba
before yeah and um the girl just drive
we saw The Ring camera dude she [__]
dropped the the Boba thing and the the
plastic cups I kind of like the ones you
have at June B right if you drop them a
certain way oh crap it'll crack at the
bottom so so Tiff is like she just got
like this new shirt or something and
she's I was like babe the delivery's
here she grabs it picks it up it just
spills no
and she's like this [__] jerk and
then we looked at the camera this [__]
just was like come on
dropped it out I don't think I don't
think I've ever ordered Thai food one
[__] time without it being like soup
at the bottom of the bag why does it
always like that always Tom Yum on the
bottom they tilt that [__] I always know
too when I get it I'm like I don't know
it could be a [__] mess but it's
delicious I feel like they come to your
house like this
that sucks sometimes you're like [__]
man this guy probably couldn't get a job
anywhere else and this is his last
resort because one time I ordered like
pho and then like uh I'm so excited I
went to his uh he's like I think he
messaged me he's like can you come help
me because I think there's like a bunch
of bulls so I went to his uh to his car
he pops his trunk and he goes and he
goes oh man the soup outside
[Laughter]
not in the bowl and I looked and the you
know when they have like a big order the
soup was soaking through the cardboard
box and there was nothing in the [__]
bowl and I was like oh [__] I just feel
bad when this guy probably couldn't get
hired anywhere else I was like oh that's
cool man
oh no dude I ordered it outside thank
you let me give you a tip oh you did man
that's why I feel like
and he was just he was like oh pops up
oh [__]
oh what'd you do with it you go drain it
in the [__] sink no I just somebody
just missing one Pho we just had to like
share it and split the rest I swear at
Thai food places they take the bag and
then they they sit there and they put
all your trays in order and then they
take like a little bit of time to go
water balloon it stays warm dude hey
what's up with this one this is dry what
the [__] you got to get your [__]
tummy I'm juicing this thing
[Laughter]
I've completely got the wrong order and
it was like this dude brought I think we
ordered like Mendocino Farms or
something and this guy brought us like a
bunch of like fish tacos and burritos
and I was like hey man this is this
isn't ours and he goes oh man hold on
let me go check and I knew he went to go
check and there's nothing in the bag
that he's checking right so he goes in
the back and he that's where he carries
all his his orders and I couldn't I can
clearly see there's nothing else in the
back but he's like oh let me uh let me
check and he's like looking at like in
the bag and he goes oh that's the only
bag I have man and I was like yeah I
know he probably gave some someone else
your food and he's like oh
oh no dude that was it they just [__]
left he just [__] left we didn't get
an order or nothing do you think some
other family was like
fish tacos soggy fish tacos that sound
like that's gonna suck but it's fine we
can only afford soccer fish tacos and
they're like holy [__] this gave us 22
sandwiches
each sandwich is 22.
medicinal Farms that place is wild
that's good though it's good but oh my
god dude get a little couscous like
that's fourteen dollars
this place is crazy
the worst one I got was uh worse than
the soup outside the worst thing I got
was I was like [__] I really want we're
all feeding for this let's get this and
it was a far delivery so we're like okay
they're gonna be in like 50 minutes
that's fine and then so every time we're
like you know when you're really craving
something you're like checking okay cool
to get closer closer closer and I'm okay
cool down the main street they made it
right I'm like [__] yeah I'm like babe
let's get ready the food's gonna be here
it's already been in the car for like 15
minutes hey babe
the people
get to the table get your drinks we're
about to eat and we're like this
and literally [__] two blocks away
they canceled the order
oh I hate that like if you would have
canceled before I could have just
reordered but now it's like we've
already been starving for [__] like
I'm like Oh my what's up hey when that
happened
find you what happened I think they
couldn't find me they're just like [__]
it that happened too when we were at the
other office oh I'm like dude just
what'd you order now I gotta know I
forgot but it was something I'm like oh
soup inside yeah yeah I'd rather have
soup outside because you could [__]
around and like do something with the
rest I didn't I don't have a funny one
my most recent weird one though is this
dude who definitely looked like he was
down on his luck he was like 20 minutes
late with my order so I was already
ready to come outside and just be like
yo like what's you know what the heck
and he comes and he just flustered with
[__] he's like ah man dude I just had
the the worst day I'm like that's an
interesting way to start right I'm like
hey man you know don't worry about it
he's like nah man blah everything is
just terrible nothing's going going
right and stuff yeah I was like it's all
good let me let me get my food and he
gives me the food right I'm like hey man
I hope you have a better day he's like
no man I told you it's it's just it's
not gonna work out man if she's bad whoa
I was like okay dude wallowing all right
man and then that was it maybe that's
why nothing's going well for you bud
maybe this is the weirdest [__] I
literally walk out you know when you're
just shook by another human being you
just don't know how some people are so
open huh what the [__] he's like I just
saw somebody die but here's your
hamburger yeah it was so weird that
would have been that would have had
somebody over here yeah there would have
been like reasoning yeah you know yeah
oh I understand I'm sorry you're going
to felt like a dark cloud that's like
you know cartoonishly hanging over a
human being and that's his tactic every
time he's late it's just a pity party
kind of dude yeah no I like it this guy
was trying to reach out and he's like
I'm hungry
[Laughter]
me and Dietrich ordered postmate and
then like we both went why is this guy
look kind of familiar the delivery
person and then when he rolled up uh we
realized it was like a dance Legend like
a an idol to us oh [__] and he was he
delivered the food and we felt so like
we went up to him we were like yo it's
an honor bro like
this is so weird that just made it way
worse for him yeah and you could tell he
was a little bit like embarrassed that
he was like delivering and we didn't
know what to like do or say because we
wanted to acknowledge that like you're
the legend like you're a God and but
then not make it feel like what are you
doing now you know what I mean like it
was a strange interaction did you go
like oh can you show me something real
quick I I had that moment uh when I was
working at jumbi at the on the register
this fan saw me uh it was like you're a
dance god dude no he was just dude
looking at me he was like oh my God and
he goes why are you working here
yeah he hasn't watched in a minute huh
he's like
he's one of those JK Nails
I was like I was like yeah dude like I
was like I don't know YouTube didn't do
so hot he just played it I was like what
would you like you know like these are
these drinks are really good he goes you
should try this and he goes I just I'm
just in shock I didn't I didn't expect
to see you here today and I was like
yeah I think I'll get something and I
gave him a drink and I'm like yeah he
goes wait so what are you doing in
Hawaii and I'm like also me and David we
opened up the shop and he goes oh this
is yours oh I haven't watched you guys
in so long that's what you that's what I
would have said I'd be like will you
guys stop watching so now you
because you guys
don't watch no more I have to I was
exiled from the mainland
[Music]
foreign